here's another thing we don't need new
Christmas music I'm [ __ ] tired of
Christmas music we got enough Christmas
music [ __ ] stop making new Christmas
music
we got enough got enough Christmas music
we have perfectly good Christmas music
everyone loves it one goddamn station
plays it for eight months in a row
starting in May we got enough but SIA
decides she's got to release her
Christmas album called every day as
Christmas
[ __ ] lie out the gate and it's all
original Christmas music so even the
good Christmas song that's all original
that's you know it's risky man if you're
gonna go out there with like brand-new
Christmas materialists it's tough how
many recent Christmas classics that's
what I'm saying very few like the one
that what's-her-name Mariah Carey made a
kazoo all I want for Christmas is you
that's like one of the newer ones and
actually really cold dare you that stuff
this is the cover of the album by the
way this is that creepy looking that's
that girl she uses in all our videos
Maddie Ziegler that girls that's not her
no you never see see his face because
she keeps it covered oh that's one of
her singles is like I'm wrapping my face
up for Christmas it would work though
because she always covers her face up
now here's the layers the tracklist of
her new album new clothes lot of words
these are original Christmas songs okay
underneath the mistletoe all right
underneath the Christmas lights every
day is Christmas as we mentioned [ __ ]
live idol tracks sunshine sure when you
think of Christmas you think of nice
warm sunshine puppies are forever
oh I want to see that movie so bad by
the way another [ __ ] line by the way
puppies are forever
best case scenario they grow up and
become dogs worst case scenario
right that's all I'm saying puppy Lake
puppies time to a cinder block and
they're not forever
I didn't do it I just said it why did
you have to bring dead puppies and do it
man because she's lying to us with
puppies are forever yeah but it's a
kinda lie
yours is a horrible truth part of the
universal victim series drowned puppies
ohoho is one of the new singles ohoho on
our album oh ho ho don't be such a
[ __ ] prick that's a duet with donald
trump ho ho ho
snowflake snowman these are [ __ ]
awful just by the titles I can tell
they're awful but my favorite one by far
is Santa's coming for us
that's [ __ ] terrifying has either
threatening or really erotic it's the
story of a couple comes down the chimney
into like you know [ __ ] we don't want
a gift what we want is for you to come
from right yeah open up that sack Santa
give us some eggnog oh stop it you're
all grown ups
[Music]
you
[Music]